people who are willing to give their
blood sweat and tears make for better
more profitable companies people who are
only there for their own selfish needs
and we would be willing to jump ship as
soon as they get a better better offer
they're not the best people to help
build a company for the long term we can
throw money at people which will last
for a while and you can make a company
look successful for a while but it
doesn't mean it can last we can't judge
a ship by how well the crew performs in
calm waters we judge a ship by how well
the crew performs in rough waters and
and the problem is is is in good times
we don't use all that extra money to
take care of the people you know we use
it to distribute and distribute them and
hard times come sometimes there's not
enough padding and the cultures have
been fostered over that time but that is
the irony which is when we lead with an
infinite mindset and the leaders that do
lead with an infinite mindset have
disproportionately more successful
companies more innovative companies more
profitable companies all of which are
strong enough to last for a very very
very long time
and not because they just have the
financial wealth to weather storms but
but the company continues to grow and
innovate and reinvent itself so that's
it's relevant in the face of new
technology and changing tastes and
politics in the world so that is the
great irony but it has to be genuine
meaning to say that I care about my
people because they're a means to an end
it's like we only we only like you
because you helped us make money makes
us not only feel used
but that that we're a mechanism for
somebody else's success where when we
say we care about our people and money
is the mechanism by which we can take
care of people you know the more money
we make the more we can take care of our
people and serve our customers it has a
profound impact on our desire to give
more
[Music]